how does it feel to be here tonight at
the 15th annual biffer awards presenting
one as well
very exciting yeah I think it's going to
be a really fun evening it's often I've
been before and people are in a very
Christmasy mood so so there's lots of
celebration and what have you've enjoyed
particularly this year in your own
career um well I just finished a film
with ray Fiennes called The Invisible
Woman which was an extraordinary
experience and Kristin Scott Thomas and
just to be with those two people who
I've grown up watching and admiring and
trying to learn as much as possible from
them what can you look forward to next
from you so I'm going to Sundance in
January I have a film called breathe in
which we're showing for the first time
out in Sundance can you give us a little
bit insight into that film well it's
about a relationship between a young
woman who comes to live with an American
family and about her how her presence
changes the dynamic of that family it's
with Guy Pearce and Amy Ryan's record
who are both incredible yeah so quite a
sort of darker story than we than others
that I've made before and going forward
what would you like to be working on
next oh gosh well you never know really
until you until you read the right thing
and then and then it hits you so I just
try and be as open as possible and
and see what comes along and is it
important for you to work in the British
film industry in an independent film as
well
yeah definitely I mean without
independent film I mean if you look in
the past you wouldn't have got all the
great films that we've seen it's
absolutely vital that it's supported
because you can tell more unusual
stories you can take risks in a way that
sometimes you can't with higher budget
pictures so tonight you've been
presenting an award haven't you no tell
me a little bit about what that means to
you um well it's a it's so good anyway I
was saying earlier because I think
independent film is in the process of a
very exciting time but but quite a
difficult time obviously so it's nice
that everyone can get together and
celebrate or it's attempt to celebrate
the amazing stories and amazing acting
that we've seen in the last few months
and I've just been so enthralled by
broken and sightseers and and seeing
unusual stories told in an exciting way
what are the films that you've seen this
year that have meant a lot to you in
terms of independent movies um well
those two I mean I was just sightseers I
don't know if you've seen it but it just
totally was just blew my mind I mean he
is a phenomenal filmmaker and I was just
so excited to see something that's
completely breaking genre or you know
it's not a costume drama it's not a
social drama it's it's expanding both of
those kind of limitations and in terms
of indie filmmakers and actors who are
out there who would you love to work
with next um well I'd love to I've been
watching a lot of folks fear Coppola
recently I've an of her films and I'm
looking forward to her new film that's
coming out next year
you